[Music]
what up guys welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want
and today we have our ask an expert
segment
and we got eric here what's the proper
way to introduce you
money mentor yeah money mentor tax
advisor tax advisor fractional cfo
fractional cfo money therapist money
therapist but for just
accountant right that's the general and
you're good at [ __ ] you said yes
very good at it very good good [ __ ] all
those terms sound so complicated and
intimidating when i hear accountant i'm
like i understand what that is you're
good with
numbers and money but everything else
i'm like oh i don't know
but also with like those like
professional terms i also want to like
get it right too so that's how that
that's true um so i have a question and
i always wondered this
right just even till now
what is like how much should i save up
before i start investing or whatever
because like now with everyone talking
about stocks and crypto and whatever
um i also get a lot of questions from
fans and they're like
hey i got like a thousand bucks should i
like invest it and
and what do you think is a good coin to
get into or like should i buy uh
tesla right now i know it's like i could
buy it with a thousand bucks
and for me i don't ever know how to
answer that even for myself
because i don't know when is the right
time to get into investing
and when i should be saving you know
that's a really good question i hear
this question a lot and so
the challenge is right now is a lot of
folks are obsessed with immediate
gratification
they see the stock market pop and they
see people making money on tesla
and obviously on social media people are
only going to tell you about their wins
and right now in the bull market
everyone's a winner right it's easy to
say that you're an expert in crypto
when crypto's gone up like ax from
earlier this year they're not an
expert in crypto same thing like same
thing like in the stock market
everyone made money this year right so
everyone's an expert so the challenge is
when you're looking at investing you
want to look at it from
you want to look at from two
perspectives if you're looking at get
rich quick
that's a sprint that's gonna be
short-term
high risk probably not going to be
successful but if you're looking to
generate true wealth you're looking at
running a marathon
right you're looking at the next 10 to
20 years so it's too far away
i don't got that long to live man i need
gains now
i've got five years and i'm done i got
two years to buy ferrari what do i do
so let's say for example you are looking
for let's say for example you are
looking to make money
relatively quickly and relatively
quickly let's look at that as 24 months
anything below that that's really
speculation if you're looking at making
trying to make money in 24 months
to be honest investing in the market
let's say for example you double your
money in 24 months you go from a
thousand to two thousand dollars
that's that's even getting my dick hurt
yeah you don't you don't have a boner on
that one i've been in crypto since 2013
nothing gets my dick hard except for
extreme gains
which is unreal by the way oh yeah like
our idea of what we expect is very
unreal right it is and it's it's hard to
duplicate past success
it's like a drug it is a drug what if
you've had four
pretty good past successes and you know
we didn't cash out on any of them
but will you what if you cashed out your
principal though
so then you're just writing profit i
think it's pretty damn good hey that is
pretty good
so the to go back to that that question
if a person had a thousand bucks
in in my opinion and again i am not like
your specific financial planner right
you want to see your normal guy
or gal um i personally would invest it
in skills i would invest it in utilizing
some type of a skill or or talent that
will allow you to actually make
more money because the thing is if
you're trying to go from to double your
money
and you're going from a thousand two
thousand dollars not really exciting but
if you're investing a thousand dollars
into a program
or certification to teach you being a
welder or to lay carbon fiber or to be a
programmer or to
i don't know learn about social media
you can use that new skill set and make
50
000 a year 100 000 per year and then now
you take that additional money
and turn that into investable assets
right yeah so
the challenge is a lot of folks they see
what's going on in market they won't put
money into it and don't get me wrong
there's nothing wrong with investing
little pieces over time dollar cost
averaging
but you're wanting to go for the long
haul if you're looking at having a
thousand bucks
and you want to make money fast i would
invest in one of your own skills
and that's like the first step investing
is getting your i guess your occupation
to a point that you're happy with the
annual revenue that's like the first
step
absolutely the challenge that we have
right now especially on social media
if you go on youtube tick tock
everyone's talking about all
these side hustles right i got seven
streams of income because a
millionaire's got seven streams of
income
but if you don't have your number one
stream of income locked down and making
as much money you can in it
why are you gonna segregate your time
and distract yourself by trying to pick
up two or three more side hustles
because you can't dance about the other
ones
yeah that's true i got one one job but
if you got seven i do this and i do this
and i do this and then do this
you can make tick tocks
yeah i wouldn't do seven streams
simultaneously i would
build the seven because it's like one
you do that well
you're getting like let's say a thousand
bucks a month on this and it's
it's now manageable to the point where
you only work one day a month or
something so but in the beginning to set
that up you're probably gonna
work 30 days you know the whole month
until it's ready and then you knock down
how many days
i think that's what they don't tell you
about the streams of income right so
like now
we have multiple businesses and things
but they're all
ran kind of part time like for this
channel we work six days
a month and so with the income that we
receive
it's because over the years from doing
several years of non-stop work we've
able
we're able to manage it this way and
then when i see the them talking about
this
this this multiple streams of income i'm
like y'all are crazy man that's just
overworking
that's like seven jobs like it's like
you're working at the restaurant and
after that you're gonna go work at the
bank and after that you're gonna be a
parking
attendant and it's like that's literally
what the seven streams of income is
and gary v told me to go to yard sales
so now i also gotta go there
damn on the weekends do you think
there's a like
a number like a general number that
people can be like like you know like
say five thousand or save two thousand
or
or like how would you come up with that
number yeah like let's say after you
you invest in yourself and you do get
the uh your
your i guess one stream of income strong
what's the next step towards investing
now
yeah that's a really good question so
the next level up now that let's say you
have a strong
stream of income and you're doing well
with that you want to start investing
you want to start looking at investing
in things that are tax advantaged
because anything you do to save tax
money is pretty sweet you're getting
like a bonus on putting money
in so if you're a normal person out
there that's employed you got a nine to
five job and you offer a 401k
with a match i would invest as much as
you can into that
and the moment you max that bad boy out
then you're like okay i have additional
capital or additional money that i want
to set aside and save
why does 401k have a tax advantage
that's a good question so when you look
at the way society and tax structure is
designed
they basically have societal constructs
inside of it to incentivize you for
doing certain things
that you'll get tax breaks for going to
college you have tax breaks for getting
married you have tax breaks for having
kids
you have tax base for putting money away
for retirement so when you think of that
you're like okay
there are certain incentives that the
government's saying hey you should do
right be being an entrepreneur is
probably one of the biggest tax breaks
out there
so i recommend to all folks that if you
have a side hustle
pretty sick tax break so when it comes
to 401k
the government knows number one if
people start saving on their own they'll
be able to retire and not be straddled
on
holding onto social security for so long
we also understand that
the challenge is a lot of us especially
if you're an s corp or you're an
entrepreneur or you're
a person working nine to five you're
paying self-employment to actually
paying medicare and social security
the reality is in 10 years from now it's
not going to exist so 401ks were
designed back in the 80s
because they kind of knew with actuarial
tables that this stuff wouldn't exist
anymore
so if they give you incentive to start
saving on your own now you're not going
to have to rely on the government later
to
live on retirement why not teach this
[ __ ] in schools then if they want us to
do it so bad
okay so do you want to hear the reality
of it or do you want to hear the
conspiracy
do you want to hear the conspiratorial
side of it i love conspiracies
okay so here's the challenge and and
america
is a really fascinating country that's
been based
and built upon this like this unicorn
story of capitalism
but the problem with capitalism is
america really isn't truly capitalistic
it's an oligarchy it's an oligarchy and
we have socialism for the wealthy and
the corporations
and then we have social we have
socialism for basically the wealthy
folks
and personal responsibility for the
individuals they got to pull themselves
up by their bootstraps
yeah that's what they say all the time
personal responsibility pull yourself up
by the beach
all the big guys get the biggest please
print money for us
right right so i was in this
conversation with a friend of mine and
i've my friends from all walks of life
i'm a libertarian like i'm pretty
independent i vote all across the board
right
so i had a buddy of mine he started
chatting to me about and he had this
specter of socialism
it was like bro did you know that
because of covet and because of the tax
cuts
corporations got over two and a half
trillion dollars of
of our our tax money preach right
and so people are like oh socialism
suppose bad i'm like wait the
these corporations got socialism but now
when you hear of
people in politicians saying hey we want
to give the average people two thousand
dollars suddenly it's socialism
psych we wanna give them fourteen
hundred dollars yeah it's like fourteen
hundred bucks to change that right
the best today's video is brought to you
by raycon
wireless earbuds
i've been using them because i was
jacking off in the other room the other
day
and then geo was like yo your porno is
way too loud so i was like okay i'll do
it in private
so i put it on no i'm just kidding no it
actually helps up
now it helps out a lot because we just
moved our barbell office yeah
and so now we have a bunch of people
working in there now
and so you know everyone's either like
video conferencing or working or like
listening to their own music so it's
good to be able to put those bad boys in
and be
zoned into my own world and work and
watch what i have to watch that's true
because
um when i used to work in the office i
would just say
shut up right but then i realized that
doesn't create a good working
environment yeah and it doesn't
make people feel good about themselves
so the best thing to do
is use my raikons and i put it in my ear
and i listen to my own music
while i tell them shut up in my own head
yeah
and then i can focus on my work without
bothering my co-workers
yeah and they work really good because
they last for six hours so you just
gotta charge it once and you don't have
to like ah man you know every time we
hear that goes
like ah damn i gotta charge it again oh
charge it once last the whole time
you don't have the wires all up in your
freaking arms and getting tangled it's
wireless it works really good it fits
good so when someone says bart you go
it doesn't just fall out when you do the
whiplash things here
and then it falls out yeah it stays in
there yeah and the cool thing is you
know when you're like me
and you're sweating at work because
you're like working profusely
and you have all your sweat like beads
coming down
you don't electrocute shock yourself
because it's sweat resistant
and water resistant so if you're working
in the rain
like i do sometimes because i like to
double task shower
while running and working and be
eco-friendly
and be eco-friendly yeah uh i i want to
make sure that my earbuds are not going
to electrocute me
and thank goodness that these are water
resistant and they're
half the price of the other premium
audio brands oh who cares about them
recon is offering 15 off all their
products for you guys and this is what
you got to do to get it go to
buyrecon.com
off the record and that's it and you'll
get
15 off your entire raycon order so
feel free to grab a pair and a spare
that's 15
off at byraycon.com off the record
one more time buy raycon.com
off the record and get 15 off so he did
so there's a challenge and that the way
that
our government was designed and the way
our economy was built
it was literally built on the back of
exploiting workers slavery was a big
part of why america grew so
fast and that notion that structure has
hasn't changed now we don't
traditionally have normal slavery in
america right now but we have debt
slavery
so we're taught in america to be
consumerist
to buy more stuff we don't really need
to impress people that don't really care
about us
right but what happens is we get our
instagram though
yes it's all for social media it's
offered so i don't want to impress
people but i do want to buy things i
don't
need yes i love that yes yeah hey i'm
killing a car with bart so we can have
horns that when we honk it goes
i love that bark at each other over and
over
but it's got to be a car that like the
dumb and dumber car
with the dog yeah i'll show you guys how
to write that off
but then so that's the challenge is we
have this this effectively modern debt
slavery
now here's the thing that the way that
it works right
in order for these large corporations to
can you having the massive profits that
they do
they have to continue exploiting workers
and pay them as little as possible
so it keeps them almost again dentured
servitude but we feel like we're
willingly making that
decision so by educating folks about
finances by educating folks about wealth
you're effectively chopping off the
wealthy
the owner class of america from their
their
ability to exploit workers because the
moment you teach people about finances
and tax and all that stuff outside of
calculus and outside of
all these other things that aren't
necessarily useful in today's context
that financial education is going to
empower the average american yeah and
the challenge is when you start
empowering
average americans you start unifying
people politics is all about
bringing people apart the further that
they can pull us apart the easier
they're able to control the way that we
do things
so your conspiracy i have to say is such
a conspiracy
is that congress works to keep us all
divided
and financially stupid so that we can be
better
debt slaves such a conspiracy man
yeah i'm not really buying it
so i'm not saying everyone in politics
is like that we have some really good
politicians but there's there is this
ongoing
oligarchy there is this ongoing ruling
class
and you know people call deep state but
they don't really understand what that
is
it's really corporatism that has funded
and basically backstop
congress and the presidency and the
senate
by lobbying dollars by all these things
and
by and large you're able to get these
special sweetheart deals
that don't benefit american taxpayers i
mean
this stuff we we talk about a lot on
this channel as well as um
all the time so we can just sit back and
kick it there's also
there's also clear evidence of
politicians
you know being a part of let's say
deregulating oil or whatever
and then after they leave office guess
what they're one of the board members
to texaco or one of the oil companies or
chevron right
and then you go i wonder how that
happened
and people are still fighting about all
these issues that
really don't help them you know and it
sucks
because i think they know exactly
what the general public care about yes
and they know how to get people angry
and
everyone out there including us we don't
want to admit
that we're getting played as a fool and
the issues that we care about the things
that make us angry
uh we really are fighting for you know
and i think generally people
have a good heart and they want to fight
for what's right
not knowing that it's a distraction
they're getting misled all the time and
pulled in different directions but no
one wants to know they're getting fooled
right
yeah and then for us too even though we
might be a little bit more informed on
the back end
we're still getting fooled as well all
the time and we're just like man how did
that happen
i don't know and then and then you're
going oh these republicans are so dumb
and then the republicans are these
liberals they're so dumb and it's like
honestly man we're all dumb because
we're getting [ __ ] but at the top the
neo liberals and the neocons
are doing the same [ __ ] they're doing
the same [ __ ] the old school
democrats and the old school republicans
they play the game
but that's a whole different uh thing
that you know but every mr smith that
goes to washington
either has to join or they could kick
the [ __ ] out yeah
yeah no one's working for the people
it's lip service for the people but i
guess it
i guess what i'm trying to say here it
all boils down to
the system of this debt slavery uh
and money and the way that we can all
empower ourselves is to
understanding how this money works
because the more small businesses and
the more empowered people there are
there's more competition for these
corporations for example like when
walmart would come to these small towns
they will basically destroy the downtown
and the small businesses
and that's only because the small
businesses cannot compete with such a
giant like
amazon and all these guys can get the
cheapest prices and all this stuff right
so
but with money know-how technology and
whatever it gives
these little guys uh upper hand and
we're able to see
maybe in the future we can go to things
like alibaba or whatever
even better where small businesses can
go direct and get cheaper prices and
and that's how you can compete with
walmart or whatever but without people
knowing how to be an entrepreneur i
think it goes right back to
hey i only have an option of working at
a company
yeah and don't get me wrong like
entrepreneurship isn't for
everybody it takes a special kind of
crazy person to want to be an
entrepreneur a lot of folks
they work in the jobs that they do
because they feel like they need that
stability
they need that title and that's just
part of their identity so there's
nothing wrong with not being an
entrepreneur
but that being said like i firmly
believe that entrepreneurs are like the
one of the biggest changes in the
like biggest changes for good in the
world because if you look at nonprofits
they really can't do too much and they
have high administrative costs and you
go to the
charity advisor or guide star whatever
it is and you can see that a lot of them
have these
expenses and they don't really provide a
lot of services and the government
really can't provide much either because
they have to span this large
swath of folks whereas entrepreneurs
like i've advised and i've i've guided a
lot of entrepreneurs and i've seen a lot
of them too
move into like a four-purpose model
where they're still wildly profitable
but because of their profits they're
able to designate a portion of it to
their favorite cherry
like ethical business like toms and
stuff like that which is really big
i have another theory for the
entrepreneur thing right like
we make less than what three percent of
the workforce or whatever right but then
i know the system of large corporations
and working
is an actually a new thing in human
history where most of human history
it's at it's been aside from the whole
like
um you know like like where warlords and
kings basically
enslaved the people like once for the
most of american history it's been small
farms and small businesses
running a lot right or like so our
ancestors were
essentially entrepreneurs in this new
system of
working for corporations is a new
working system so they created a really
good
branding of stability and safety you
work for this company but how often do
people get
laid off fired companies go down and
then so like they say oh
i'm so stable working in this job but
it's like
they're immune to accepting that hey you
got fire
that's instability right there that's
the same thing as losing your business
but they don't see that as oh i lost my
job well i'll just find another one you
know it's this
i don't know to me it's more of a what
do you call it like a perspective thing
so entrepreneurship feels scary and
difficult because it's so
foreign but humans have been doing that
more than working for a company i think
so what would you say now
that was i guess going back to the
original topic what is like the second
step into investing is there a certain
amount that people
so you have your job you have your ira
or your 401k
uh is there like a and then you have
money left over from that then you
start investing that yeah that's what i
would do right
so the challenge that a lot of us have
in america because we see all these we
have all these consumers tendencies
is to start living below your means so
let's say for example you're making five
grand a month 60 grand per year
and after tax taking home 3 500 bucks a
month
now at that point a lot of folks they
end up trying to live a seventy thousand
eighty thousand
a year lifestyle at least in the bends
and buying the the chanel purses and
they're the rollies and stuff like that
and there's nothing wrong with that
right because we all like nice stuff i
love fast cars and stuff like that
but the challenge is when you live above
your means you're riding on credit which
is basically what america is doing right
now we're like i think like
30 some trillion dollars in debt which
is ridiculous
now if you start realizing that
consumerism and buying stuff you don't
really need is
effectively bleeding you dry and you
start changing your spending habits
and i'm not saying like don't buy the
latte and don't enjoy the latte because
we should all enjoy like what we've
what we've achieved but if we start
changing how we bleed our money out
that should free up monthly cash that
you can put aside
for yourself and the biggest thing for
controlling your expenses controlling
your expenses yeah
and the biggest thing is started putting
the vision in your head of why you're
doing it
because it's easy to start doing it when
you're all motivated and you hear other
people doing you're super motivated
about it
but then motivation is fleeting it it
dies off
and so anything you can do to make it an
automatic withdrawal or an automatic
deposit to a savings or into
an investment account a wealth front or
whatever is probably the most powerful
way of doing it because if it comes out
your bank account out of sight out of
mind
you pretend you don't have it and just
automatically go into your bank account
just set aside what you can afford and
you feel comfortable doing
and then when you see the little gains
from your hundred dollars a month
they're
200 a month or 300 a month and you start
seeing the games for me like man
i want to put a little bit more aside
and then you start actually building
true wealth that way
the whole idea of investing is a lot of
folks think that you need a ton of money
to do it
no you need a little bit of money over a
long period of time and you have good
habits
yes i think what you just described is
just forming a new
good habit for yourself i had this app
that just deposited like
20 bucks a week for me and then i opened
it the other day
and it had like fourteen hundred so i
was like oh [ __ ] and i
sent it to buy aetherium with it that
one you got one
what a thing good job
yeah so first stable income second if
you're going to invest do it in
something
that is a a tax uh
benefit kind of thing i have what's
called a
sep ira uh and for me
i can max that out with and it gives me
a discount on tax
and this is what's called like pre-tax
money so business owners we get taxed
at the end of the year versus someone
who is an employee who you get
taxed and then you get your paycheck so
uh what i get to do is i get to
put my pre-tax money into this account
and then i when i retire i can you know
get it but
as it grows over the years because it's
you know putting it into stocks and
things like that
the money grows and that's kind of how
i'm investing
and then after that i don't
invest i gamble
we all do a little bit here you take on
gambling so
gambling can take a lot of different
perspectives right a lot of experiences
so okay yeah so when you invest in
crypto
um i use the word invest very loosely
understand it is still very speculative
so you don't want to put anything
into the crypto markets that you don't
need to worry about
right that you if you have a fear do we
zoom in on joe's face right now
well you know the problem is i don't
worry
[Laughter]
he's stoic because like the crypto
markets are really effectively a roller
coaster
oh yeah they're fun they're fun oh
you're talking some rollercoaster riders
maybe we can talk about that next we
should
[Music]
[Music]
you